what are your thoughts on the sixth what
are your thoughts on the sick like how
the mcconnell and the left sells it and
then how many on
the mega camp and trump's camp sell
january 6 yeah i mean look i'll tell you
what i think of it just you know
unvarnished i think it was a terrible
day for american history and i think
that the images that we saw in that day
are are terrible and we can never have
that happen again i do not hold
president trump responsible for anything
that happened on that day uh anyone
who's a trump supporter after we had
spent how many different speeches and
ads and everything saying we support law
enforcement we support law and order
how how anyone could go and do that
that's why i've always had questions
about just how much how really some of
these people were actually trump
supporters where they were rabble
rousers or if they're you know some
people who just had a screw loose uh i
do think that it's unfortunate what the
unfortunate too light of a term i think
it's pretty disgusting what the doj is
done on people who say for example
didn't enter the capital i think if
you're again you can be outside the
capitol there's no law against that if
you want to go out there and say um uh
go and send these back to the states to
have further debate on that's fine no
one should be having any other civil
liberties infringed upon or have their
life ruined simply because they're
outside the capitol if you were if you
assaulted any police officers if you
destroyed any property
then i think you need to be held fully
held accountable for everything that you
did if you're outside peacefully
protesting
so what people protest outside the
capitol all the time and
uh but again it's the images of that day
are things that for a lot of people it's
gonna define an entire generation
politically so on on j on um i don't
know what day what this was the one year
anniversary this year when ted cruz said
the following of all the things that
january 6 was it was definitely not a
violent terrorist terrorist attack he
said that the next day but you know
later on that day but earlier that day
he said it was a
it was a insurrection it was a terrorist
attack then tucker carlson came out i'm
sure he saw that and he
hold his held his foot to the fire and
said hey what is this and he said no no
that's not what i meant he says look
you're a man of words you know words
you're a guy that knows words you said
it did you mean it how could you say
something like that you realized the
repercussions of this and it was a very
uncomfortable day for ted cruz do you
think do you think that was by the way
your mic is on do you think that was a
situation where ted
was maybe that morning he's like this is
an opportunity where i can go and i have
to have a different position than trump
if i'm gonna run myself you know do you
think that was one of those moments or
do you think he just had a bad day and
he said the wrong thing so
i worked for ted in the primary in 2016
before i went to before i went to trump
and
uh
just doing the quick rewind if trump had
run in 2012 i was gonna be his campaign
manager and i just assumed he was never
going to run i thought he got his
apprentice deal renegotiated he was
going to stick that so
signed up and partnered up with ted
ted
doesn't make mistakes speaking
i can't speak to what his thought
process was
i i've i've never seen him actually
misspeak i mean he's so i don't know
what all he was thinking or went into it
i am glad that he went and cleaned it up
i still think ted's a pretty important
voice but i would disagree as far as the
you know the the insurrection talk or
saying that this is some kind of
terrorist thing i would i would disagree
with that yeah i'd be curious because i
think trump's got a memory and he will
remember comments like that being made
you think i know i i think that's either
going to work in his favor or it's not
going to work in his favor you know it's
meaning ted i'm not talking about trump
because
you know
you think romney's going to play any
kind of a role in the next two three
years or he's done he's done that he is
so dumb i mean he's i i don't even know
how he'd get re-elected he's young
compared to abiding into trump
uh he is i thought romney was how old is
romney he's he's in his 70s
right i don't think it's that big of a
difference i think that i think it's i
thought he was late 60s is what i was
he's also saying mate 74. got it well he
looks good
i'm not going to that's right that's
what some of that that sweet bain cash
will do
what do you think happens with the gop
establishment the romney's of the world
the cheney's the the mcconnells
and the
you know
mega crowd like what's that relationship
look like moving forward yeah there's
always going to be an inherent conflict
and i don't even think it's necessarily
unique just to republicans i think it
might take a different form but you see
even with
the democrats and the progressives and
the people who want to change washington
from the right or the left uh and then
people who say actually we're washington
we're the ones you know this is the
hunger games this is capital city we're
the ones who make the decision the rest
you guys just just go and live with it
there's always going to be inherently
something and look it is i will tell you
this whole changing washington thing is
really damn tough uh it's like going to
the casino and saying i'm going to beat
the house it's like these people who say
i'm going to beat the
i'm going to beat the doj in some kind
of legal thing they have unlimited money
unlimited resources and they're just
going to keep pounding away
there's always going to be some of that
conflict but as far as the the
republican base overall nationally it's
solidly with trump i mean you look at
the way that he single-handedly changed
the trade debate you look at the way
that he's single-handedly changed so
many of these uh the international
relations the america first dynamic i
mean you know it was only a decade ago
that you know someone coughs somewhere
and we're sending us troops five minutes
later now we're taking much more of a
wait a minute do we need to go and stick
our nose into in all these efforts
that's all because of trump and just the
fact that biden has left so many of
trump's china policies in place i think
it just tells you how much trump has
moved not just even the republican base
but the country as a whole into
realizing the the existential threat to
china for the long term that's that's uh
that's that in itself you know if you
were to biden camp how would you sell
that you're you're a campaign manager
for biden how would you sell the fact
that you've kept many of trump's china
policies well you're wearing this you
just claim them as your own
well
yeah i don't know about that i think
you're you're right i mean that's that's
what uh
that's what a amateur campaign manager
is going to say right that's what an
amateur campaign manager is going to say
but this is an opportunity to come out
and you know win the opposite side and
the guys in the middle to say listen at
least this guy's being given some kind
of credit on what happened there but you
have to stand to your point you know and
say well this is our ideas well we have
to we got rid of every single idea that
he had the only thing he the only thing
biden can do is say actually trump
wasn't tough enough we went even further
the country is so moved uh in the other
direction with regard to china i think
we are moving towards a true deca it's
never going to be a complete decoupling
but you see the way that it's it's going
i mean these these uh the decoupling of
these economies is happening so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]